[Music]
[Applause]
bringing Ross Tucker CBS Westwood one
color analyst host of the Ross Tucker
football podcast he was on the call for
the Colts and the Vikings Saturday
afternoon okay
what are you saying in the broadcast
Booth well half time is going on of what
you think is going to happen with the
Colts and the Vikings
well first of all Dan I am thanking the
Vikings for a personal delivery of
unbelievable food to the uh broadcast
Booth which was amazing but also a
little bit awkward because it's halftime
these people are being so nice to you
and they're losing 33 nothing I mean
they're getting embarrassed so it's like
you want to smile and say thank you but
you don't know what to do because
they're getting hammered honestly at
halftime I was primarily talking about
Jeff Saturday uh The Unbelievable
coaching job he did to get those guys
ready to play with nothing to play for
and this could be something that he
builds on the last three games and maybe
gets the head job and I said except for
the Vikings they just need to get the
first score you know they just need to
get the first score it always starts
that way it sounds like a cliche but
once you get the first score and some
positive things happen the wildest part
about the game to me Dan
is that not everything went their way in
the second half I mean you're talking
about a team that had the greatest
comeback in NFL history and not once but
twice they had fumbles returned for
touchdowns that the refs blew dead or
Jefferson has to leave because Gilmore
hits him in the head rhaeger comes in
stops his route and cousins throws a
pick I mean it's I mean they probably
could have come back from 45 points down
if it wasn't for somebody
all right
we're just talking about Ross is uh
joining us from Green Bay and uh
hopefully your connection will be good
is it dial-up service there you're gonna
be okay
am I slow oh that's a that's a bummer
it's Wi-Fi here in the in the hotel room
in lovely Green Bay I'm on the call
tonight with Kevin Holland it was good
for my podcast this morning hopefully it
holds tough for you guys uh just to get
you ready for Kevin Harlan tonight uh
fritzy would you give Ross a little
Kevin Harlan
Ross it's good to have you in the booth
it's a big game tonight at Lambeau Field
Baker Mayfield and Aaron Rodgers
three-nothing lead for the Rams will
they hold on this 13-26 left in the
first quarter and the Rams want to talk
about it
but wait why if the Rams are up three
nothing with 13 26 in the first quarter
why do they want to talk about they
lined up wrong or something else illegal
formation there or something just let
him go
by the way uh Ross would you like to
vote on most valuable Danette
oh geez
um that's tough you know what's funny
Dan like one of the first couple times I
filled in for you I went on uh pardon my
take with those guys and they made me
rank the danettes which it puts you in a
really uncomfortable situation so I love
Seton and Marvin but I don't have a lot
of interaction with them it's either
Paulie reaching out about filling in for
you if you're sick or something about
just listening to the show oh okay yeah
um
I like seating with the soccer stuff
um I'm a big fritzy guy I feel like
everybody is always knocking fritzy like
I was listening the other day Dan and
fritzy must have like given you the
signal he wanted to talk and you and you
said
yes Todd it was it was subtle and it was
amazing it was like it was the last
thing on Earth you wanted to do was go
to pretty so I'm going pretty somebody
has to be team pretty I'm Team fritzy
all right
well Todd might be uh sweeping all four
categories
open by the way all right I mentioned
this first hour
that Sean McVeigh feels like there could
be one foot into coaching one foot in a
broadcast booth at some point here if he
looks at his team you know are they
going to be competing for playoff spots
in the Super Bowl
but then I also thought if he if he's
found his quarterback in Baker Mayfield
at Baker's age
you don't you know Stafford may have one
or two more years if that is that enough
if Sean McVay can find his quarterback
and it happens to be Baker Mayfield uh
right there in front of you
well that's what makes tonight's game so
interesting right I mean that's what
makes the rest of this Ram season
interesting there's still a lot of
unknown as it relates to Stafford his
neck injury next steps for him if Baker
plays really well I do think that's part
of the reasoning
for McVay whether or not he decides to
come
of
yeah we got a bad Wi-Fi connection there
let's see if we can get him on the phone
a couple more phone calls in here best
and worst of the weekend uh Jeff in
Detroit hi Jeff what's on your mind
today
Ross Tucker's back with us we were
talking about the Rams and Sean McVeigh
and Baker Mayfield and you said that's
why that makes this game interesting
tonight
yeah just because I think if you are
Sean McVay
who your quarterback's going to be next
year and moving forward is obviously
extremely important we don't know what
Matthew Stafford is going to do I saw
where McVeigh said he doesn't need
surgery that surprised me as a guy
that's had a bruised spinal cord before
in my neck
um I would I thought he did need surgery
but I think there's still some chance
where Matthew Stafford decides not to
play anymore if Baker plays really well
down the stretch and McVay kind of likes
him and kind of wants to work with him I
think that that makes it more likely
McVay continues to coach if Baker plays
really poorly and Stafford decides not
to play
I mean who's the Rams quarterback and
and is McVay sticking around for that
yeah you know this could potentially Dan
be the other side of trading as many
draft picks as they did for Ramsey and
and everything they've done this is kind
of the other side of it where you don't
have the depth you're not able to
sustain that years down the line Cowboys
and the Jags and the Bettors were on the
Jags and that's why I thought
something's up here because I didn't
know if this was a trap game for the
Cowboys they've been spending time
talking about Jalen hurts and the Eagles
that game coming up this weekend but
they couldn't stop the run
where where's the Dallas defense that
we've been waiting for or that's been
there and you know kind of disappeared
it's a really good question because it's
interesting to me how many people are
like talking about Dak Prescott after
that loss and it's like wait hold on a
second first of all
the overtime pick six walk-off and hit
Noah Brown in the chest I mean that
wasn't a bad throw by Dak they put up 34
points even when the Jags came all the
way to take the lead once again Dak led
the Cowboys down the field to get the
go-ahead touchdown it hasn't been the
offense I agree with you Dan I don't
know what's happened to the defense I
know they've lost some guys
but I think people have I don't say they
figured them out
but they've lost too many guys in the
secondary like the corner Anthony Brown
opposite Trayvon Diggs and because
they're a little bit undersized up front
and they're Built For Speed and that
pass rush if you don't get them in a lot
of obvious passing Downs where Parsons
and those guys can go nuts
you can move the ball and the Jags kind
of move the ball on them at will you
know early in the season we were talking
about the Cowboys like a top five
defense they've been anything but the
last few weeks
also the Bengals and the Buccaneers the
Bucks are up 17-nothing Brady at home
trying to rebound after one of the worst
games of his career
and the Bengals come to town in that
second half dominated what changed
couple things changed number one uh the
Bengals changed up their defense their
decoordinator should be a head coach
this off he's in Louisiana rumo so
impressed by that guy I mean they went
from giving up 17 points unable to stop
Mike Evans in the first half to Rolling
coverage to Mike Evans totally shutting
him down and then on some level too the
the Bucks just imploded I mean they try
a fake punt
and Giovanni Bernard is the only one
that doesn't know what to fake he's not
ready for the ball then they fumble back
to back Brady fumbles they fumble and
exchange I mean it was like bad news
bear stuff for the bucks in the second
half
and now the Bengals I mean not only are
the Bengals in the driver's seat to win
the AFC North they've got a very
realistic chance to get the number one
seed because they still play the bills
in a couple weeks and I think it's a
Monday night game and that's going to be
an unbelievable week 17 Monday night
game with the number one seed in the
entire AFC potentially on the line
yeah you have Buffalo at 11-3 Kansas
City 11-3 Cincinnati at ten and four uh
Jalen hurts coming off the worst game of
the season going into the the Dallas
game handicap this matchup we're going
to have on Saturday with Dallas in
Philadelphia
well what's so interesting about it Dan
is there are people in Philadelphia
already pointing out that the game
doesn't really mean that much for the
Eagles right I mean they have a
three-game lead
with three games to play so the only way
they don't get
the division championship and really
even number one seed is if they lose
these last three games which is unlikely
so there's a couple different scenarios
right there's number one
I think the idea of resting anybody here
in week 16 is ludicrous but if there's
things you notice on film
that you really think you can exploit
against the Cowboys it's a little bit
it's a little bit more interesting I
mean do you show it yeah so there's a
pretty decent chance they play against
each other in the playoffs with the
Cowboys being the likely five seed that
that's a very real scenario so I I
expect the Cowboys to bounce back home
game uh I I think they'll play very very
well although on the flip side that was
the worst the Eagles have played in a
long time three turnovers uh several
mistakes and they still won I think the
Eagles would like nothing else but to
just cement everything and be to eat
beat the Cowboys Saturday and get this
thing over with have fun tonight uh our
best to Kevin Harlan thank you Ross
absolutely I will give him that thank
you guys that's Ross Tucker host of the
Ross Tucker football podcast Westwood
one tonight if you're listening on radio
Rams and the Packers you can follow him
uh at Ross Tucker NFL and his daily
30-minute Ross Tucker football podcast